china arremete nuevamente contra los
países que han impuesto medidas
anticovid a viajeros procedentes del
gigante asiático para Beijing se trata
de una politización sobre el tema del
virus
china Siempre cree que las medidas de
prevención de pandemias tomadas por
todos los países deben ser científicas y
apropiadas Y no deben usarse como una
oportunidad para involucrarse en
manipulación política prácticas
discriminatorias o afectar los
intercambios y la cooperación normales
entre las personas cada vez son más los
países que les exigen por ejemplo
pruebas negativas de covid 19 en China
la eliminación de las estrictas
restricciones destinadas a frenar el
virus han desatado Un aumento en el
número de contagios para Europa se trata
de una preocupación legítima en palabras
del gobierno francés y por ello buscan
blindarse
ningún país quiere ver un brote en su
territorio no después de todos los
esfuerzos y sacrificios realizados en
los últimos tres años
Beijing se enfrenta a críticas por el
reporte de sus cifras la Organización
Mundial de la Salud dice que los números
actuales en China reflejan la situación
real particularmente en términos de
muertes Henry week aprox de lo que
conocemos cada semana aproximadamente
10.000 personas mueren de Kobe 19 pero
el número real probablemente sea mucho
mayor desde el cambio de política las
autoridades Solo han reportado al menos
cinco fallecimientos diarios mientras
expertos internacionales predicen que
solo este año se pueden registrar más de
un millón el país se prepara para que
una Nueva Ola del virus golpee las zonas
Rurales ya que millones de personas se
alistan para viajar a sus ciudades de
origen para recibir el año nuevo Chino
este 22 de enero